herr bildersuche ein bisschen gas neben
nächster für die vergehen und ja
[Musik]
deutschland daran aufatmen denn wir
ziehen die diese dreckschleudern aus dem
verkehr
als sein und mit unserem amerikanischen
ökomobil natürlich an den benziner mit
sechs litern hubraum machen wir uns auf
den weg
wir sind vom tüv rheinland ja wir würden
ganz kurz mal die die abgaswerte messen
wenn das für sie kein problem ist und
nochmal mit dem gas geben
herberger sommer ein bisschen gas neben
nicht so viel wissen und ja die werte
sind natürlich schon relativ bogen also
was ist das für ein gefühl jetzt mit mit
so einem wagen herumzufahren wo man
jetzt weiß dass die ganz schlecht ja
also ich hab's ja in der presse mit
verfolgt ja habe jetzt natürlich
erlischt hat jetzt im moment mit
gedanken gemacht dass der welt erlaubt
betroffen sein könnte ja nicht dass von
ihnen irgendwie schriftlich oder wir
haben jetzt hier zu mir ein bisschen
leid aber aber ganz ehrlich gesagt wir
müssen ihnen jetzt mal hier diese diese
diese plakette darauf machen warum jetzt
einfach auch weil und dann schieben sie
auch kinder integrieren baden weil das
sie gewarnt sind mir das dass es sich
bei diesen wagen dann doch eher um eine
eine ja ich will fast sagen todbringende
maschine handelt
doch mal ein bisschen gas geben
europe und der schlick aus
frau wagner haben sie mal der der der
schlägt bis nach hinten aus das heißt es
das ist ganz ganz weit hinten das heißt
also da kommt ordentlich was raus das
sind da sind stickoxide
sie machen den boden sauer und führen
dazu dass man husten muss husten
schnupfen heiserkeit das ist alles alles
möglich bei diesen emissionswerten
ich muss aber jetzt kurz gucken ich habe
dann noch damals in der lehre
beigebracht bekommen da gibt es noch mal
ganz zuverlässige methode hier in der
suppe ist immer noch das beste wenn sie
jetzt mal kurz gas geben könnten noch
mehr so richtig schön hoch baum gekracht
[Applaus]
doch jetzt stellt so den dieselautos
sind lebensgefährlich vor allem die von
vw
deswegen müssen wir brutalstmöglich
durchgreifen und den messestand nicht
machen
vom tüv muss das leider schließen
hier herrscht lebensgefahr begeben sie
nach hause ich würde etwas einfach die
leute bescheuert genauso aus nordwesten
mein ausweis ich bin vom tisch
als ganzes gesehen noch mal die pflicht
ja danke ja dann gehen sie mit mehr zu
sehen
[Musik]
guten tag ich könnte ich sie für ein abo
des heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab